Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one.
To David P. Here is a call from Dr. Ryan,
I don't know why he's asking me about this.
He's the doctor, but it's a question about
masks.
Take a listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, this is Dr. Ryan had a question.
Do you think that this will become a seasonal
thing and and basically a permanent feature
of society?
And you just kind of the context for the question.
OK, so because, you know, conservatives have
pushed back against mass.
They're pushing back against vaccines.
It seems like we may not reach for her testimony
and the virus can continue to mutate, and
it's just going to be harder, harder to control
and it becomes like the seasonal flu that
just keeps coming back.
And now we have data things.
You know, it seems likely in my mind that
stores would turn on a mass required sign
in this season.
Yep, covid season.
This is going to be something that's coming
around every year.
Speaker 1: I think that there is a real chance
that in some parts of the country, mask wearing
becomes seasonal.
And, you know, there's a very kind of ominous
article in The New York Times that's spreading
about we may never reach herd immunity.
I think in practical terms, for this as a
pandemic virus, we will reach herd immunity.
I do think this could become and it's not
me.
I mean, epidemiologists say this could become
sort of an endemic seasonal thing.
You might get a booster vaccine booster once
a year, every couple of years, like for the
flu.
But I think that I'm less sure about stores
saying, oh, during flu season, you will need
masks to come in.
Maybe.
I think more likely as a first step, you will
just see people in high risk groups that during
flu season, which seems to correlate with
when you might see seasonal covid as well,
high risk people might just start wearing
masks.
I know people now who used to kind of be aware
of flu season as a time when they were at
higher risk, but they didn't really behave
differently.
Who now are saying?
I think during flu season I'll wear a mask
to the grocery store between, what is it,
October?
And, I don't know, whatever flu season is,
there's a few month period there.
I'm just going to wear a mask.
And I think that before we see stores go to
some sort of seasonal mask thing, we will
just observe society and see if there are
people who either socialize less during flu
season or wear masks when they go out.
I think it's completely plausible.
And the other thing I've said is there's going
to be a long term psychological impact of
this pandemic.
There are people who I mean, listen, there
are states now where the coronavirus risk,
based on the percentage vaccinated, is down
to flu risk in the sense of there are some
states that in a typical flu season have five
deaths a year, that now we're down to 10 covid
I'm sorry, five deaths a day over the course
of the year from flu that are now down to
10 deaths a day from covid.
And as vaccination continues, you are going
to see covid deaths get down to the single
digits, same numbers as flu.
That is not likely to feel the same as before
all of this stuff started.
And what I mean by that is there are people
who are have realized, thanks to this pandemic,
that they were maybe accepting more risk before
during flu season than they're comfortable
going back to.
I think there's no doubt about that.
I think there will also be PTSD problems,
agoraphobia, people who just don't want to
be out there just feeling I'm safe at home.
I think I'll just stay home even if things
get better outside.
These are going to be a lot of psychological
aspects to this.
But I do think that doctor, Dr. Ryan is certainly
on to something there about the future of
masks.
And that would not the U.S. would not be unique
in that there are lots of countries where
during flu season, you see masks worn just
as a matter of a matter of protocol, I guess
we would call it.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Republican Senator Tim Scott is claiming that
Congress is close to a police reform deal.
Is it true?
And what would it look like?
Also on the bonus show, North Korea is back
and they are warning the United States over
Joe Biden's big blunder.
Do they need food aid?
Do they need medical aid because of the pandemic?
Typically, there's this cycle and that's when
we hear from North Korea.
And we are going to talk about maybe the best
argument for increasing the size, not physically,
but the number of members in the House of
Representatives, the size of the House chamber,
I don't really care about it seems plenty
big.
But the argument about the size of the legislative
body, what is that argument?
I will tell you today on the bonus show will
discuss whether you think it's valid.
And producer Pat getting his second vaccine
dose today.
How is he feeling?
We will find out in mere moments on the bonus
show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dotcom coupon code available.
If you want a discount, it's better.
Twenty one will see you on today's Boeing.